foreign
[Music]
okay so uh the folks that we have here I
mean the resume uh if you were to if you
were to stack it I guess vertically like
we're going like geostrata layer you
have a Brian Cowan you can check out his
dates at briancallen.com Mad TV alumni
has I mean I don't know how many
podcasts what are you up to 19 a day now
yeah 19 a day can't stop won't stop you
know what I'm saying bro then kind of
kind of a little bit of a rivalry
because you have SNL alumni and of
course has been uh all over the country
uh you may have seen him in I mean I
don't know how many films you've been
but you know you're proud of stand-up
yeah yeah they call Jim they call Jim
the original okay it's jimbrewer.com is
where you can go see his dates and then
of course you know him you love me on
the show very often nickdip.com wait a
minute we went you went in a Geo what
order
no for going away You're the Cretaceous
Period
I thought you were saying if you let if
you
accomplishments it would reach the moon
well it was geology but I mean it's it's
for comedians you guys so it's
technology I love geology I'd love to
start on geology
study of rocks are you more you see a
lot of people talk about carbon dating
you strike me more as a selenium dating
I can't believe you know me so well no
it's almost like the back of my hand God
and what about this man are we still
minding that in the Congo guys because
these kids need to eat so but seriously
though this is one thing honestly I've
been wanting to get you guys in a room
together for a while now um there really
aren't many think about it like what did
you did you swallow a burp and you
surprise yourself I'm just looking at
the hole I swallowed a joke I was gonna
make a racial crack go ahead no go I
mean that's why we're here
you can just block that out like a rape
beat that VCR word please don't you love
it I had to pull the Chelsea Handler
where I had you do a bit before and then
I took it and made it mine how do you
how do you know what Chelsea handled
does you watch that
[Laughter]
this is me hiding my face yeah well
because you have to go back to that club
that's actually her her new book are you
there God it's me woman who loves a box
of blacks and people talk about how
strong and independent she is I'm
kidding she's a terrific person she's
actually she's actually she seems like a
good I like I like Chelsea all right do
you yeah she proves she's an idiot but
go ahead you think everyone's your
friend no I've known Chelsea forever
she's she's good people I knew Hitler
for a few years well so does Tim Kennedy
he found him now
uh look this is pretty rare that you get
this amount of people there used to be a
lot of shows like this you think about
like like tough crowd with Colin Quinn
Nick was obviously their Pioneer there I
mean you were regular
um back in Serious XM of course you had
Opie and Anthony where there was just
sort of comedians in and out now that's
really sort of changed quite a bit
um everyone here is at least sort of
right to center right uh there's been a
shift almost a tectonic shift in the
landscape of of Comedy because
you say right like most of us were just
living our lives
right off the bat Brian I'm not I'm just
saying that the world started going
crazy and then all of a sudden I was
just sticking to my traditional beliefs
tradition all I was saying is two plus
two is four and all of a sudden I'm now
not just right I'm far right like where
I went right you can say you're a man if
you're a woman and you just decide you
are and I got I don't they're all these
things that started happening where I I
couldn't even follow the rules because
they kept coming down from
a 2000 2017 2000 probably 2000 that's
when you sort of started identifying
more as traditional conservative you
felt like that's when I started
identifying as a woman yes but with
muscle yeah but but well so do a lot of
the men who identify as women yes but
the George Floyd thing really went crazy
where you used to start seeing things
like sound who's that
who's this George Floyd you speaking oh
that nice black guy that did porn no he
was like a good boxer but um
but he does them he does the the Philly
shell but um yeah yeah a really good
Philly show yeah but but um it doesn't
protect your neck I think what happened
was I started seeing things like silence
is violent first I was told to shut up
because I would never understand white
man yeah and then I was told that then I
was told that silence was violence so I
had nowhere to go and I started to read
I started to realize your aim is
actually destruction it's not even just
not even a talk to me yeah and then I
saw that the left wasn't even interested
in talking to me and then covet hit I
see I missed your traditional myself I
used to think that violence was violence
I didn't know but but they didn't say
Simon says you were about to say
something there well no no I did that
too that was that was the first time I
started seeing the lunacy of creating
violence
by clearly creating violence and
division listen I did a show in Harlem
in the early 90s if if there's one
police activity in any neighborhood even
the neighborhood I grew up everyone's
out in the street right and everyone's
videotaping I just I thought it was
bizarre that there weren't 20 camera
angles and 300 people in the area
because I'm telling you right now you go
to any poor area roll up in a cop car
and I'm telling you right now everyone
stops what they're doing right and they
all come outside well be careful don't
actually do that because that's highly
illegal to be imitating an officer but
the point remains yes yeah it's a great
Point
disconnect and you would know these
stats better than I do but I started
seeing a disconnect in 2020 I think
there were 10 million arrests and nine
unarmed black men were killed and and if
you look at those cases each case was
pretty egregious to begin with where
they were coming out you know so there
were a couple examples I went 10 million
so 9 10 million arrests 9 million
unarmed black men were shot those are
pretty good odds all of us would say you
have you you got a 10 million 9 and 10
million chance of winning whatever it is
are you willing to bet a million dollars
I put a million dollars on that I'll
take those odds all day well I would
because I'm white the 10 million you
talk about are interactions yes yes yeah
just sent directions
those are good that's well there's a
reason there's a reason they pull the
unarmed statistic because if you're
armed you're actually far more likely to
be shot by the police as a white man
yeah black man yes it's several
multiples unarmed and here's what they
don't tell you is when we're dealing in
the realm of Statistics right armed or
not that change is the dynamic between a
cop and a civilian uh unarmed depends on
how you're reacting to the cops are you
throwing are you throwing hands at the
cops are you trying to run are you
getting physically violent yeah exactly
so that's why they only pull the unarmed
statistic because the armed statistics
are are shockingly uh different
um I want to ask when Nick realized he
was I think because Nick was always this
way I mean go I go back and watch when I
realized that I was kind of conservative
yeah when I uh bit the head of my
pastor's
that's sort of that was the change
that's what happens
I I don't know like he said it's more
about tradition my parents weren't
political right Common Sense uh type
people my first open mic was in
1987 or 88.
um I'd say yeah and and somebody comes
up after my first open mic and goes
you're Politically Incorrect I didn't
know what that meant at the time yeah
um I'm like okay that that's the guy
goes that's like sort of the future of
Comedy boy was he wrong I mean he's
still not there but did you guys did you
guys all find what I found the most
alarming was when I saw a legacy
mainstream media all saying the same
thing oh yeah they were telling me that
two plus two was 16. and I was like wait
why is everybody saying this in this
mountain it's not making why are you not
mentioning the stats yeah why are you
not looking at what we all know is the
truth well I expected that what
concerned me was when Comics were
stepping in when Comics were throwing
other comics the bus and when it was a
Witch Hunt I mean you saw what happened
with Louis CK or all these people I mean
it was just like they pull up the ladder
behind them like like Peter Dinklage now
with the with the stuff yeah we
about to say something like I think it's
dwarf yeah I forget though he was
talking about mainstream media and two
plus two equals 16.
serious answer to your question like I
started listening to Rush Limbaugh yeah
and people you know I was like what are
you an idiot he's a fat lob because
that's what they're being told right out
of the gate he's a racist he's and I
kept listening going I haven't heard a
mean word out of this guy's mom no yeah
I heard nothing but then Eddie you know
then I shut my mouth at the comedy so I
remember
um what's his name funny uh like improv
off the top Jewish
Jewish nevermind Jewish kid I mean that
doesn't narrow it down no oh come on
Andy kendler oh yeah I mentioned Rush
Limbaugh in The Green Room a tough crowd
he goes you know
you don't listen to that guy oh no and I
go you don't read Chomps y do you
tell the dumb yeah he shut his
mouth well the thing is if you say if
you say Rush Limbaugh in the mirror
three times and Lee Andy Kindler shows
up yeah no exactly I can't believe guys
like that and I love Kimber I think she
I think he's his friend is anybody to
ever do this yeah and he sort of said
the same about me he you know doesn't
like my politics or whatever right but I
wouldn't do that if I heard him talking
left-wing horse I don't mind I don't
mind disagrees with me I don't mind no
exactly I love the idea that someone
like Andy Kindler has a different point
of view and I might learn something I
don't really care about that right you
need that in this club
and this is the thing that I would say
the left does and you guys have all
experienced this to some degree all
right and it's completely unsure where
they go oh no it's fine I don't disagree
with this politics will say it's that
he's not funny that's what they'll use
as the attack right they'll say no no
you're not funny all of a sudden people
who thought you were funny think you're
not funny and they say it's not because
of politics they treat you like you're a
bad person it's not just so you're not
funny I didn't care anymore right I
don't care it's like I know it's funny
yeah we were always funny so if they do
the whole Like There's a comic out there
I don't even want to give him the credit
of and he went out there started special
right out of the gate talking about oh
you know he we're all we all got masks
and we all did what we're supposed to do
and blah blah blah and he went into a
scenario and he goes unlike a Jim Brewer
unlike and he added two other guys and
he goes and that's why it's okay to wish
them to be dead well I was like that's
something Jesus yeah yeah who's the guy
so I can hate him no no no no no no
we'll talk about him okay all fair is he
doesn't have anything going but
[Laughter]
trust me he's having gone well for him
but that's a great point on a larger
scale like they paint Trump as Hitler
right so of course you'd want to kill
somebody as horrible as Hitler right so
that's and then the rest of the sheep
join in they're convinced that he is as
bad as Hitler so yeah if we have to
lock him up during the you know
yeah when the election comes along I'm
I'm worried for Trump's uh actually for
his security well that's how you got
punched by abroad and Birkenstocks like
because literally someone's probably
showing up going this guy's like Hitler
and she feels emboldened
um I mean well I I I I like to reframe
the story okay like I went three rounds
um
okay all right fine but she was she was
you know she was crafty she was little
she's mentally ill I have pictures of
her on my phone if you want to see I'm
not kidding you no no I remember you
were on my show I'm looking at a black
eye yeah I'm looking at her dad like
this and the father set me up he's like
yeah I really enjoyed your show all
sudden bang what you ever get suckered
and you're in shock right it's a weird
thing no if it was a guy it's always
moving yeah yeah even when you're
talking to somebody yeah they call me
the Cobra Well no they call you the
parakeet but the point so she's she
cracked me yeah
there yeah I remember so she I still
have a flat spot let me tell you
something
I know her name I know the old man's
name and it's not over I'm not I try to
go through the legal channels they
wanted nothing to do with it it was all
broads at the courthouse uh are
you blind you in a wheelchair we can't
help you you still I go but if I punch
that girl in the face you could
help her right and they just you know
he's gonna show up at the Croc Store
when she's there like two weeks from now
you never got me
never got me back two weeks I got a flat
spot on my face I got it in the back of
my head I picture myself
in New Jersey you don't feel it you get
popped at a gig it's almost yes yeah
after the show Jimmy I was shaking hands
and the old man set me up I say old man
he's younger than me but kind of he
looked like you know so he knew it was
up he goes these These are the words he
goes to me I really enjoyed the show but
my daughter wanted to punch you in the
face he didn't even get the word that
must have been her cue
I mean she almost cracked my Jeep and I
looked right at him I'm seeing like two
of him and I go did you just
sent me oh no it's nothing like that and
I I know that's what would not yeah no
it's it's and uh and and like you said
she thinks she has a right to do that
because she hated what I was saying she
said I was right you know racist and
then she's crying after she hit me she's
up in the lobby crying oh no there might
be a case there became this weird thing
too with white educated this this is
like it there was this homogeneous sort
of Education thing where the white
educated people
[Music]
you know whatever we'll go continue on
Mud Club but hey they had this idea that
they had this idea that they they had to
change white people for black and brown
people to be okay that was a new thing
too where it was like we have to purge
the bad whites so that the black and
white people the black and brown people
can fly through but the craziest thing
is the place where that is in my opinion
least necessary is comedy there's a
disproportion and by the way rightfully
so uh representation of black men
specifically in comedy because it's a
storytelling culture it's a culture
where things are passed down like it's a
culture busting ball it's a roasting
culture that's right like if you look at
the Top Cop you're not going to find
anyone who argues if you have a top five
list and you put prior up there is
number one or number two if you put Rock
Chappelle up there right you're gonna
have three out of the top five probably
six out of the top out of the top ten
Sports is the same way yeah sorry well
yeah but that's because of the tibia oh
is that what it is I don't know I have
no idea yeah this could something called
the sports Gene guys yeah the brothers
are funny funny because they don't care
they're also not shocked no you're
attacked by political correctness they
can say whatever well I know I always
would say that to Patrice right to his
face when it come off stage after saying
he's in a horrendous rape jokes yeah and
I go yeah you can get away with that
and he goes I know he
wouldn't deny it that's why I loved him
he goes I know you can't go up there
try to wouldn't you say it I
mean in comedy of all the places like
that don't really require social justice
as far as you know ensuring outcomes
it's pretty diverse and it has been for
a long time and we're still winning
yeah it has been diverse but they're
definitely they tried I believe they're
losing the battle though the whole 100
the censorship is they're doomed yeah
you have guys that uh they try to get
rid of Rogan they try to do something
with Chappelle and neither one budged uh
it's I think it's uh those are great it
just makes it stronger it gives you
something to push back against if you
want to make people funnier but you also
put them in a censorship is good you put
the mirror on them dude I mean how can
you
when we were kids we'd we'd go to the
carnival
and you'd pay extra money for the freak
Show to see the bearded lady and now you
go to Starbucks and pay five
dollars I can see all the beer ladies I
want why is that not funny I go to
myself why can't I say that why am I
always sudden some psycho right-wing
fanatic yeah because uh because someone
didn't even put in the effort to shave
like if you're gonna demand that we
recognize like just shave you know Mumu
doesn't cut it yeah but dresses and
beards don't go they've both been around
forever it's not a good combo no it's
not but I think the cancel thing too
it's if you're afraid
of of if you're afraid of the machine to
back you or you don't have that fear
yeah like I don't have a fear but what
am I getting canceled of yes well that's
what can you cancel I can say that
better than you back you took us I mean
I lucky enough my career was so mediocre
I've been flying under the radar
you know every once in a while of you
know
that tweet on the radio show you call it
mediocre I call it uncompromising I was
going to say here man who knows what he
wants Channel 187 on Sirius XM
as
that's where you could find me no but
but yeah but but everyone knows you're
talking about like people behind the
scenes have always I mean I remember
when Joe Rogan I talked about this when
we did the press conference but it's
true Joe Rogan I was watching this from
Greenfield Park on uh on my then
girlfriend's computer when he did the
Carlos Mencia thing and he was talking
and Carl Smith he was like he's just mad
because he's obsessed with me
with him he said Dave Chappelle and Nick
depaolo and that's when I went and
looked up Nick and I realized that I had
seen him at the Just for Laughs I just
didn't know his name yet I still can't
get on Joe's show anymore well three
times Brian put the call in give a text
I love jokes I just want to talk
fights I've actually become a student I
listened to him I beat up my wife twice
a week I'm good with this UFC
you better run a Kimora last week but he
never closes his hand he never closes
and there's shakes
see the bruises Jimmy brought up uh you
know you said canceling Rogan uh
Chappelle Chappelle was never in the
danger of being killed they will never
cancel a guy a black guy at that at that
height of Fame he's too good it just
well no it's just he's also telling the
truth well big reason is you lose too
much of the chorus of white women
because because they feel like in the
hierarchy they can't fully cancel Dave
Chappelle so he sort of gets to take
that off The Ledger Tracy Morgan says I
keep bringing this up it might be the
third time on your show but Tracy Morgan
perfect example
um somebody asked him when his wife was
pregnant what if you have a gay kill it
um that really killed his career a year
later he has an animated series yeah I
mean picture that coming out of a your
mouth Jimmy or a wife and it's
been like that forever I say why that
baby gay his hair so short
why you got such short hair gay baby
my baby I got a game I got a Gaby I
threw it in the trash yeah it really
hurt his career yeah then didn't he like
did he like go over like nine people in
a Lamborghini or something yeah no he
banged into a lady at a red light he
made a lot of money why is he walking so
slow
Jesus that's a good white Tracy that is
a that's a we uh but you know I know
you're right I mean when he said that
too I remember thinking but you know
what like they'll say again behind
closed doors when you're with black guys
in comics that's the kind of stuff
they'll joke about all that's your first
mistake going behind closed doors with
them well you and the priests oh but
that's the kind of thing that everybody
chokes around about I mean it's like
okay I don't know why we're acting like
it's about killing your gay baby I don't
know if that's like a genre that might
be I brought it up because it's a real
life example of the double standard yeah
and and if somebody at Jimmy's level
said that can you imagine if you're an
SNL and you said something like no done
you should though you should have done
it during the monologue I would have
stood up this is a sketch called killing
guy killed my Gaby it's disgusting hear
me out though guys hear me out I did it
quick well let me okay so let me ask you
this because if you go back everyone is
always sort of bemoaned political
correctness now the term is often called
you know people say woke so people on
the left will say oh they've always
complained about this but it's just
about accountability there's nothing new
do you really think is this just kids
these days or do you think it's worse
than ever today I think kids are
actually pushing back I think 18 year
olds and stuff finally yes are actually
anytime you make something forbidden in
in what I love about this country is you
start saying you can't say there are
only two genders that's a great way to
get people to start saying you know what
I'm looking around there are only two
genders or I don't think somebody who's
six foot four with a dick should be
swimming against women off and
that's what's going on more and more and
let me ask you Brian but where do you
see evidence of like 18 I hang out with
18 year olds I come I come back high
school because I got tight fitting skin
and okay
you know what this is a perfect example
I was watching I don't know how I missed
it on Hulu the uh the Mike Tyson uh
Series yeah that's how you missed it was
on Hulu yeah well you know what so
remember when he yelled at that reporter
he's like I'm gonna bend you over you
yeah and then he says um you couldn't
live yeah you love me so they include
everything in the Hulu series except
they switch
it's just hilarious because like well
that makes you gay right like I'm gonna
you till you love me and then I'm
gonna take you to Red Lobster you can
have scampi it is Dream Season I will
call you did he say all that I don't
know but it's just like he's like he's
serving him but they changed the word
that's the that's the that's
where they draw the line I'm telling you
ten guys run this planet eight
of them are
Transit right Jimmy 100 people right now
they switched that word though my father
my father's 83 and I remember talking to
him and I said
dad I was complaining like this I think
about all this stuff uh yeah
um I call him Mommy because now he
identify but I but I I remember I said
this is crazy like this this
woke and I can't keep up with the
rules and all that and these and I'm
gonna do it we're having a conversation
and he just quietly looked at me and
goes won't last
and I went what he goes it's impossible
to apply at the level of detail it's
just not going to last you'll see and
that's all he said and I think that's
the thing how do I apply these rules I
can't after a while there are more and
more people sitting around talking this
way including people on the other side
who are going ah you know women not
enough yeah maybe not enough maybe not
enough as long as the money and there's
too much time between now and then right
that's where it well you know I was
talking to Rogan I said he said we were
saying this five years ago and it's
still going on so these ideas Die Hard
you know like old Joe call me
that's what Mick Jagger said
I didn't know he said old habits die
hard then he blew David Bowie you're
about to say something for the love I
don't remember oh okay it's the wake of
bodies that would happen between now and
then that's concerning yeah you know I
mean that's one thing like Nick has
talked about and Nick of course he's
he's being um self-sort of a facing
there but uh he's always had respect of
his peers because people know how good
he is and a lot of that tells you that
they know these foregone opportunities
because of his point of view you know
I've been I was on YouTube in 2006 and
then started doing right-leaning videos
in 2008 I believe because it would get
in trouble in Canadian clubs or
universities which is remember NACA
remember all that yeah that guy they
always thought they thought because I
was young they were like yeah you'll do
great at NACA I got one college
remember him yeah I came home with uh
88. oh yeah 88 colleges
but I don't know how you would do that
today who's gonna go and select oh my
God why would you do three lesbians why
would you go would anybody say yes yeah
it's literally everybody knows those
indoctrination can't why if unless you
were a far left to believe that why
would you ever as a comic go to a well
back in the day it wasn't you know you
have a lot of like frat people and it'd
be kind of like you know that's where
Dane Cook made his bones and Jimmy uh
found Adam Sandler it was good money
back then it was good that was great
that's but today yeah how could you
saying I got in trouble back then I did
Clark College and outside of Boston it's
even liberal for Boston but this is when
this is like the bad ideas percolate and
then the people who have been
indoctrinated that come of age and get
into positions that's right government
in their own positions in Academia in
Hollywood in writer's room all of a
sudden you have this group think this
Hive mentality and that's kind of what
happens if you yeah if you start
teaching children at that age and they
go all the way up to college and
especially when you have this sort of
issue where they all come from the same
area code you can trace this back it's
not a mystery right as to how this sort
of this this this Collective Madness
yeah and it only could get this they can
take on this momentum with help of the
media that's it complete you couldn't we
have one even Fox you're gonna call that
right wing no it's good but
there's a special wrestling it's a
professional wrestling but it's good you
get this side to believe in this and
pick up and somehow we even get
homosexuals to stop fighting one another
it'd be brilliant
send the thumb desire make sure all the
media pushes out immediately put on the
Time Magazine
remember magazines that's Cloud Schwab
he's doing I remember Magnus
one was Monday
was struck the entire nation when is it
when you get the fact that it's it's you
can hear it you know like yeah
destroy one another and watch their
blood films since the streets yeah but I
think it I think it's also important
though to where I don't do the both the
both sides thing either because there is
there is truth you know and I do think
that one truth yeah it's not your truth
it's not much right people say My Truth
like well there's a truth yeah that's
what it is they say yeah the left says
yes it's just evil yeah left is no
they're all nice words for evil yeah
that's right it starts with a language
but what's good guys is that when you
say that like you just said that there
is the truth when you have this
Madness over here all it does is get it
forces you to start defining the Bedrock
you're anchored into it started it
forces you to kind of solidify your
political and moral philosophy that's
not a bad thing but but it's when you
start to see that there's a tidal wave
of insanity coming your way and you got
to go hey guys we gotta I gotta batten
down the hatches and I need I need to
figure out what I'm standing on let's
make sure we got our guns lined up and
clean and our powder is dry
that's that's that's a good thing oh you
just said when you just said there's not
your truth there's the truth right oh
yeah oh yeah but the problem is when you
have people in positions of power that's
why I always say you know they say the
military-industrial complex remember
code pink you don't hear a word for them
now that Biden's you know in office or
when Barack Obama all of a sudden it was
just for George Bush it was just like
code we don't like George W bush that
was all they did but I mean
I'm 61. I've seen all this right Reagan
was a Nazi right a George Bush Senior
was a Nazi but they all say the military
industrial complex that's why I say the
media entertainment industry big Tech
complex if there is the truth but it's a
and those are neocons it's in a well no
no these people are all far less it's an
agreed upon law military it's an agreed
upon lie that we are living that's the
issue it's when NBC ABC CBS CNN when you
have people in you know uh whether it's
a Johns Hopkins who then have been brow
beaten into submission by the trans
Community whether it's the CDC The Who
and then you have Facebook Twitter
Reddit it's a hunter Biden story big
Tech Google YouTube all of them they all
say no no hold on a second there's no
such thing as male female that's hate
speech they all say I don't know how
it's like you're not allowed to discuss
elections or you're not allowed to
question CDs it's in a they don't
believe it it's an agreed upon line it
doesn't matter how strong your arguments
are until that gets break broken apart
they start when you argue and this is
something that Rush Limbaugh said 40
years ago when you argue with a liberal
they're starting at the they're starting
at
I'm superior to you that's where they
start their arguments you start arguing
with a comedian or somebody I don't
literally believe they're morally
superior but Nick I don't mind that
that's that's as human As It Gets What I
what I go crazy over is what I would
call chaos we are embracing so when when
when the CDC
has is when when you can go as a man and
get a drug that causes you to lactate
which allows you then to breastfeed your
child and that milk because of the drugs
you have to take actually causes heart
problems in a child and the CDC and
everybody else isn't going we gotta stop
this because this is evil which it is
this is evil and Insanity when you don't
have that now we're really in trouble
now what's happening is we are embracing
actual Insanity when you have men who
can go to women's prisons and get two
women pregnant two female and before
they get moved we are dealing with
Insanity that's right when Scotland says
for if you say you're a woman for three
months and you don't have to have
anything you have balls and a beard and
get put into a woman's prison I don't
know what the we're doing anymore
but there are certain things I'm willing
to fight for there are lines you're
going to cross where I'm I'm going to
dig my heels in and I'm actually going
to fight and I mean you're my enemy
I'm not interested in being I don't want
to meet you halfway this is why you say
how did I come out of the closet why am
I why am I you want to call me right
wing you want to call me a conservative
I'm a proud conservative now because
that's the kind of I'm not going to
compromise on well
I'm trying to get in there sir no but
but no did you write that down
I don't have to did you it's right up
here one step away from banging the
podium there's a PDF that I'm about to
send out so Nick no I was just going to
say but it all starts with that that
addict you said this is only the truth
yeah and that's the attitude when they
argue with you they start at I'm morally
Superior so it doesn't matter what comes
out of your mind right and that's why
they're so quick to shut down speech
yeah exactly they want to shut down the
conversation um that took a while to
sink in I mean I I heard it years ago
but then when you when you watch it and
it's so prevalent today like they really
do think this spotter how far back you
think goes because if you really think
about just controlling people's emotions
I'd say something
if you're on the this is this is all
Media or entertainment it's this simple
in my and I
think of before everything first respect
man rip
Read All About It read all about it
you're like oh what are we reading
about if someone's what the is
going on any human situation if you come
in to God holy you you're
not gonna before you can even think
they're like now here's the deal this
person's like this and this person's
like that oh yeah and before you even
get it they've got your attention and
when you do argue with them
there is no arguing all they're doing is
repeating everything that they've heard
and they've seen and the and the
tolerating you it is the greatest black
magic voodoo uh in perhaps in human
history you know they say oh the king
whatever King they used to come
and take 20 of your money and they'd
come along well how much money you think
you we work for right and what kind of
gig is going where government which
morally dude I used to listen to Marley
all the time his interviews he said all
governments are illegal and if you
really just break down government what
the is government there for what is
government there for two purposes tell
us and it's really the only purpose for
the government is my dad used this
analogy do you trust it anymore I trust
the analogy I don't trust government no
question dead yeah well I trusted he
said a hockey and you'll appreciate this
a hockey referee no not a soccer referee
it doesn't work ball or baseball where
everyone jumps on the the pitchers
Mountain like a because some guys
got into a disagreement right in hockey
the referee he said is there to keep the
players safe make sure there's the pace
of the game is kept otherwise he keeps
his whistle in his pocket he says so the
government is there to keep us safe
meaning external threats or you know
interior threats neighborhood yep he
said uh and to ensure that people are
playing by the rules meaning they're not
stealing from people outside of that
keeps the whistle in his pocket it's not
his bit it's not the government's
business and the analogy only works with
the hockey referee so the legitimate
purview of government would be yep some
form of military yep some form of
enforcement of regulations to ensure
that people aren't being swindled just
keeping your promises that's it they're
supposed to stay out
when you're at this state where like are
you talking about where we're talking
about we don't know what a man is we
don't know what female is well that's
yeah well then if if military is in Rule
and governments in Rule and nobody's
stepping in
to go this is I don't know where you all
come from right but this is
Madness yeah if if nobody's stepping in
then I don't trust anyone that says
their government or this or whatever
none of them are to be trusted and the
thing that I worry about is
where does it go because everyone talks
about it all we do is talk about it we
talk about it I know that's what I say I
even feel guilty doing about it because
it's and what is the what does the
outcome look like because
it it is
it's not going we're letting it happen
well all right but I think I think a lot
of conservatives are and you know that
we've that's what you know mug Club is
but and by the way if you guys want to
sign up power fear lateral crowder.com
you guys can sign up and support all
this because a lot of conservatives have
cow Tao too we're like Oh They'll kill
me last right tens of millions of
dollars on YouTube on Facebook and we
only know one way we said well no okay
at least that's doing something where
you're migrating people off of these
platforms where you can hit them in the
pocketbook you see it with Bud Light
right you saw it with Target
um the problem is the government right
the scope now is so large yeah it feels
like this Leviathan that that can't be
addressed but it does start with
information and that's why the central
battle to me is still the Battle of big
Tech and being being able to ensure that
everyone here can at least Reach people
with the truth or as a Fighting Chance
who's taking marching orders from who
because colloquent says it's the
corporations that give the White House
their marching orders and I thought it
was the other way around it's well I
mean there's a little boat
Alliance at this point yeah well think
about this like Facebook so really you
have you have Facebook itself or meta
now right meta and then alphabet is
Google and YouTube these are more
powerful than for example the Roman
Empire right yeah there's more you look
at the Ottomans you look at Genghis Khan
you look at how much these people
control and you look at the benefits
that they receive directly from the
government with Section 230 right they
get to receive the benefits of being a
uh an open platform but they also get to
be Publishers and remove content
editorialize you have to pick a lane and
sometimes people will say hey it's
really bad to have a or b thinking black
with this there does need to be an A or
B either you are a platform in which
case you cannot censor material or
you're a publisher right but either way
you have to pick one because if you
start censoring material and saying this
is allowed this isn't allowed I don't
care if you're doing on behalf of the
CDC or whoever it is that day you now
are liable for whatever's on that
platform just like New York Times is
just like the Washington Post is that's
the problem with 230 it protects them
like their utility it's a new problem
that they're trying to figure out it's
one that no one on the right has done
anything about we have them on the show
and they grandstand they go look enforce
it pick a link but would you say though
that for me it's always like what they
secretly a lot of these Studios in
Hollywood have fired their Dei uh
officers because they were losing money
so at the end of the day if you start
making these movies and you're taking
politics into consideration to check
boxes and you put out a bunch of shitty
movies and and Studios start losing I
don't know 100 million dollars right but
they're not switching though that's
where I'm saying but they're not
switching it that's how you know it's
probably it's ideological exactly when
they put the money aside it's about the
message yeah
but how long does that last until you
kind of idealize you the ideology is not
going to pay the bills after a while
you're gonna go nobody's watching yeah
nobody wants to finance movies like that
they're going to go I did a movie I
remember I'm telling you I did a movie
and I remember the conversation the the
they were looking for staff you know
they need makeup people and the one
thing the producer said is he goes look
man
um uh the director and the producer were
saying yeah yeah and they're not in into
this pronoun stuff they're not into this
all this whoa crazy so they were
looking specifically and they had
questions they were kind of secretly put
into the interview to make sure that we
weren't dealing with crazy really yes
because if you if think about when you
go to that's the one no that's one night
it's not enough no because because Holly
look they're here these people are fired
they've been fired or they've been sort
of laid off I mean you know I mean
every Dei officer has been laid off for
them you're talking about like in L.A
I'm talking about big studios Okay well
that's good some of it's trickling in
but it's it's a little too late nobody
wants to deal with it the boat by
millions if they started making movies
yes yeah being well
again yeah sound of Freedom look at look
at what's happening with like Maverick
America First it crushed and they're
they're paying attention to that also it
was very it was also a lot of support
people don't realize from uh from big
voice box
of the film
you know what Stephen I'm saying you
wanted to ask who's pulling the strings
it's those people
those commercials the anti-tobacco lobby
I did not know that no but I will tell
you this I have been up against this and
I thought it was a juice this one thing
you can't talk about it did you say
choose yes
no but I was used to talk about this on
the show uh a long time ago what show is
this
now
but people because a lot of comedians
had a blind spot a little bit now I came
up you know so you said your first one
like was in 87.
um I'm trying to think back mine would
have been uh like you know early
mid-2000s I get it you're younger no but
here's but I remember here's the thing I
remember talking with comedians who had
been established going like yeah well
here's it doesn't matter as long as
you're funny I'm going no no hold on a
second you understand it's the people
who are trying to get their foot in the
door so at this point I remember being
told that open mics you can't do that I
remember one point oh Club here in Texas
that you just did recently where a guy
who wasn't the actual manager of the
club but he would he was the guy who
would tell the manager he would say yeah
yeah he came in and he did this stuff
you know we don't do that in this city
it's like an oasis you can't talk about
these topics and I would even have the
tapes and go no no the set went really
well I would tell you I've had a bombed
I've eaten since Canada or Canada and
then even in the United States too but
when you're coming up as a feature when
you're coming up as an emcee and you're
trying to get stage time they just
weren't willing to take that risk I had
been banned from colleges that's why I
started doing the YouTube stuff because
I was going these are things that at
that point it was more free than the
club atmosphere now it's kind of tipping
back a little bit but a lot of comedians
they come from the era or they would say
as long as you're funny that's that's
fine but it's not true yeah and I can't
imagine being someone today I think
maybe now it's opening up no you're
right no I think like I know for a fact
that these open mics in Brooklyn and
even at The Comedy Store from what I
understand there is there is a PO there
is a political agenda they're they're
you're not getting up and doing this
quote unquote straight white guy comedy
whatever you want to call Brooklyn yeah
you mean comedy no way I'm walking out
there I'm not even be able to cross the
bridge I know they're already never even
sees him immediately I don't think they
sound like
for some reason yeah there's always all
his villains are speaking this way well
well that makes sense all the villains
are white noise talk like this yes but
uh Steve yeah cat cat 10th a couple
years ago went to Brooklyn to do car and
they you know two times they dumped
water over it
don't fight me the fight's out there
damn it yeah
yeah man I don't know I think it's
feminism
I've been saying that I know but I
really me and Colin Quinn had this
argument for years he would say no it's
the race thing I said at the core of it
just watch any commercial I was on this
way before anybody uh any commercial how
the guys emasculated I was saying this
in the 80s yeah and then and
then
um now you can't even watch a movie it
is unbelievable what was I telling you I
was watching a movie that was fine uh oh
it was that series The offered did you
do you watch that about the making of
The Godfather no you didn't tell me the
feminism permeated it this must have
been before it happened you just told me
to watch it you gave it I didn't tell
you about that
um no they painstaking detail great
series until about the second episode
where the woman who's like the co-star
goes off on some on some tangent that a
feminist would have wrote yesterday yeah
you know this is supposed to be in the
late 60s it sticks out they might as
well have had a martian walk by yeah it
would have been more realistic the
Pain's taking detail for the you know
for the whole world and then
they throw in they have whether it's a
commercial I watched it last night same
thing a couple movies at the hotel okay
that's when you see sorry good no no I
just watched the new Predator film pray
because they switched it now from
Predator to prey and it's and he gets
beaten he gets beaten by a broad with a
bow and arrow and a tomahawk with a
piece of bungee cord on it yeah lioness
and she's like she's like I want to go
out and Hunt like you have to gather the
berry she's like I want to hunt because
you say that I can't do you have any
idea how little tolerance the Comanche
tribes would have for that they're like
oh really you want to get us all killed
we're gonna tie you now we're gonna tie
you to a post and just be thankful we
don't let you on fire and sing what
makes the Red Man red okay shut up stay
home and if you want to put some war
paint from the wild low Bush blueberries
because they have greater dye then fine
we'll do that but blueberries have great
accents but they're very hard to
cultivate they were a land I learned so
much with you they used to dye their
clothes while blueberries but hold on
but Jim had something before
the Brilliance and propaganda through
film TV everything I was just even on uh
I don't know what flight I was on and
they have your blue pan Blue Planet oh
yeah yeah it's unbelievably shot though
uh incredible yeah but what it does it
brings you in and you know whatever they
talk about the mountain goat and
the elk and the and the thing and it oh
twice I've every episode ends with but
then climate change yes yes we'll never
see a goat again oh yeah yeah exactly
dude I saw them push climate change and
being gay there's another episode of oh
I swear to God they'll pick it on the
gay go bird has this whole
scenario right and he goes to to pick up
the chick and the chicks ready to go
with him and then all of a sudden a
bunch of other guys are like we're gonna
have to fight if you're gonna bang the
chick this is how it goes right and so
he gives up and he goes somewhere else
and what happens he attracts another guy
and they ended and he goes
and then they'll spend a lifetime with
the male bird which in the end is
probably better than just being alone oh
and so you on board you've been studying
unbelievable and they're gonna live
together yeah okay this is blue pants
that's an important point because like
what I saw with the feminism movement
and the same thing with this is that
like in climate change is it's one thing
to be a feminist and say we want equal
rights right I want to be able to vote I
want right to my own property all that
stuff Steven they had a big March over
it but something else changed third wave
and quote unquote fourth wave feminism
changed from we want we want equal
rights too men are trying to kill us
a war I'm saying that
was it was never right it was never
right people are gonna get I have women
out there and they educated me it's
always been women we're there against
women voting now let me explain to you
exactly what it is wait Karen strong in
the show no people don't realize this
okay was I believe it was 19. early
1920s now what happened is for a man to
vote for a man to vote he had to be he
had to pay taxes own property being the
draft mandatory bucket Duty which means
volunteer firefighter service it was a
socialist movement catering to women to
get and say by the way you can get the
vote most women didn't want the vote
because they thought it came with all
those responsibilities they said no no
you're not going to do any of that I
said really so they got the vote there
was a period of time where men still had
those responsibilities to vote but women
didn't and the first thing they did the
very year prohibition because they
couldn't help themselves in sticking
their nose in where it doesn't belong
right away like they had to lift the
touch liquor never touched ours so my
point is the basis was never equal
rights it was special exceptions it was
not we want to vote and we're going to
be in the draft and we're going to do
volunteer firefighter service and we're
going to pay taxes it was there was a
coexistence of social the Socialist
Party the temperance movement and the
suffragette movement and that's why most
women didn't want the vote they should
vote but they should all have the same
responsibilities well whatever that I
understand I'm just saying that they go
wrong
there was there was this shift where
women were now having to fight men off
because men were trying to kill them
then you had these things that Trend
like wait what kill men yeah
rapist culture all this all this stuff
the whole me too all of that stuff was
men are trying to rape and kill you and
that's and that's what we have to do
right now and that's how women were
taught and that's how they are taught so
that's the difference between the old
school feminism and the new new wave
feminism that's and then climate change
now they actually have to deal with
actual male rapists in their prisons
exactly who identify as women by the way
that's a good example we were banned we
were suspended from YouTube because we
did the joke Alex Jones as the angel
Gabriel coming down saying like hey uh
you're gonna bring you Tidings of oh
I'll be I'll I'll deliver virgin birth
no your cellmate's going to rape you
repeatedly it was a sketch and we had a
trans and then YouTube said you can't
talk about this because at the time it
had not been been fully confirmed by
trial that the man had raped a cellmate
so we were suspended for two weeks for
doing a joke about something that
actually happened there you go anyway
sorry but climate change the same thing
right it's like you're gonna we're gonna
die if we don't do something right all
fear-based oh come on oh my God I do
love watching it though it's such a
great show to watch but yes all the time
it's just yeah no watch it watch
everyone yeah they always say climate
change I forget what the bird one is
it's so funny but he they clearly
pushing a gauge better than being a very
Sly about it unbelievable
homosexuality existence many species and
it's like no it doesn't it shows yeah
they don't show you have you seen the
problem now with the chimpanzees that
are sorry look well but they're they're
they're they're doing their uh
fornicating with the bullfrog's mouth
have you seen this yes
and he showed me that did he yes he
showed me I went wait a minute yeah yeah
what the f is this animal plants an
ongoing thing Apes do that so they
always say this like homosexual frogs
they say you know homosexuality
existence different species but they
don't show oh yeah so we're just like
apes they don't show it face banging a
frog right the interspeace like if
Harvey Weinstein was doing that in his
Casting Couch they would say well of
course he's face banging another species
that we are not yeah I watched an
orangutan Chicken in Indonesia and I
watched an orangutan grab a little a
three-year-old uh uh orangutan and it
was an adolescent male and it raped a
three-year-old uh the baby up in the
tree we're just Apes we're Apes
yeah so so yeah so you're saying that
feminists are
you saying
[Applause]
I'll draw the connection what what no I
wasn't doing it no this is a reason no I
was just saying when he said uh you know
all men are potential rape that's what
the feminists say hey even a broken
clock is right there right and all women
are potentially right what's the term
called you guys thought I was going with
some race no I don't
what was it I'm just saying there are
there's a reason there are rape laws
what and I'm that reason listen
no I am the law all right hey it's
nickdip.com jimbrewer.com
briancallen.com we're going to continue
on mug Club right now if you're watching
what's that sign up Live with credit.com
yeah way to step on your own plug you
know they support you too so but a lot
of that conversation but hit like share
if you want more Murderers Row uh we're
gonna continue piss off YouTube thank
you Rumble
all right
[Applause]
foreign
thank you